This year the Ri things have been very space-themed,
so we're making a very special demo film for
you, looking at all the fun little experiments
that they've done aboard the ISS.
The recreate a spacey weightless environment,
we took a page out of the astronaut training
book and sent Kevin Fong, this year's Christmas
Lecturer, on a parabolic flight. A parabolic
flight can create pockets of weightlessness
by going into free-fall mode. We wanted to
look particularly at how water behaves in
microgravity.
The major force acting on water in microgravity
is surface tension. In a drop of water you
have molecules that are being pulled equally
in every direction by the molecules that surround
them. The water molecules on the surface of
the droplet don't have water molecules surrounding
them on all sides, so are pulled inwards towards
the centre of the droplet. This imbalance
of forces creates an internal pressure that
forces the molecules into a shape that has
the minimum surface area while maintaining
a cohesive surface.
This also explains why droplets are round:
the spherical shape minimises the surface
tension needed, as described by Laplace's
law. The effects of this force on Earth are
relatively weak because gravity counteracts
it quite strongly. In space, however, surface
tension really comes into its own.
For the first one I have this wet towel. You
can see it's quite wet, but when I wring it
out, all the water leaves and it's left pretty
much dry. In space it's a bit different. You
can see Kevin wringing the towel while floating
in mid air, but the water isn't behaving like
we just saw. Instead it's bunching around
his hands, and occasionally small globules
break free when he shakes his hands. Without
gravity to pull the water downwards, the surface
tension keeps water adhering to itself, and
turns it almost into a gel-like substance
that clings to most surfaces. Water is quite
special in this regard because it clings very
strongly due to its hydrogen bonds.
The second demonstration is an excellent study
of fluid forces. What I have here is a beaker
full of water and a ping pong ball floating
on top. It's pretty obvious that the ball
would be floating, because it's full of air,
and air is lighter thanw ater. The question
is, what would happen in microgravity? You
might expect that everything would move upwards,
but the reality is much cooler:
The ping pong ball is covered in a layer of
paint that makes it hydrophilic. This means
that it's wettable and the water wants to
creep over the ball. When we remove gravity
from the equation, the ball sinks into the
water.
As you just saw, water does some incredible
things in a weightless, space-like environment.
I wish we could've shown you more. For more
space-related content check out our digital
advent calendar at rigb.org/advent.